stop get your little finger away from
the add to cart button on Amazon because
right now is literally the worst time to
buy an iPad and if you don't believe me
I'll prove it to you in this video with
five very good reasons and trust me by
the end of this video you'll be thanking
me getting right into reason number one
everyone probably already knows by now
that Apple's annual iPhone event is
happening in about three weeks with the
rumored date being September 12th and so
far everybody's getting hyped about the
new iPhone 15 lineup and some new Apple
watch models but what many people are
failing to realize is that Apple also
tends to release brand new updated iPads
at the same event for example for three
years in a row including 2019 2020 and
2021 Apple has released a brand new
budget iPad model at the September event
now they didn't do that last year since
they waited until October to release the
brand new 10 generation redesigned iPad
but still that's also only two months
away so any unsuspecting consumers
buying one right now would be really
disappointed if a new one came out just
three weeks from today which is why I'm
trying to warn you now as far as the
actual leaks and rumors for the 11 gen
iPad we honestly shouldn't be expecting
too much because it just got a full
redesign with the 10th Generation model
however what we can expect is Apple to
upgrade the chip in a big way currently
the 10th generation iPad comes with the
A14 bionic chip which is directly from
the iPhone 12 lineup but seeing as apple
is expected to release the a17 at the
September event exclusively for the
iPhone 15 Pro Models I honestly think
that apple is going to give this new
iPad the a16 chip which is much faster
than the current A14 and I believe
that's happening because way back in
2020 Apple released the 8th generation
iPad where they gave it the a12 chip
completely skipping the a11 because they
didn't upgrade anything else due to the
fact that the 7 gen iPad received a big
design change with a brand new 10.2 inch
display with thinner bezels so because
nothing else changed on the 8th gen
model they gave it the a12 chip to
sweeten the deal and I believe they're
going to do the same thing this year
skipping the a15 and going straight for
the a16 ship to sweeten the deal for the
11th gen iPad so trust me if that ends
up happening you definitely don't want
to buy one right now with the old A14
now getting into reason number two we
have Apple's most popular iPad by far
the iPad Pro with around 44 of the total
iPad market share and we've been getting
tons of rumors of the iPad Pros getting
one of the big biggest redesigns ever
and it's coming in around six months and
the reason this is such a big deal that
I really want to stress is because Apple
usually has Tick Tock Cycles where every
couple of updates they'll give us a
redesign with major feature changes and
in between that we get chip upgrades as
well as a couple of other feature
editions and well looking back at the
history of the iPad Pro we got the first
models in 2015 with 9.7 and 12.9 inch
sizes then in 2017 we got a brand new
10.5 inch size and the huge 120 hertz
promotion display update and then in
2018 we got the biggest redesigned ever
with a new display that's edge to edge
with rounded Corners with a new flat
back and sides as well as the new Apple
pencil 2 with its wireless charging
system but then after that things
started to really go downhill the 2020
model was mostly just a chip upgrade
with a new camera and so was the 2021
model a chip update with a new mini LED
display that was only for the 12.9 inch
size and then once again in 2022 we got
another chip update with nothing else
being added that was actually worthwhile
so that's basically three chip update
releases in a row so we are way overdue
for a new design and major new features
so anybody buying right now is seriously
going to regret it when the new ones
come out in the spring of next year and
speaking of the new features we should
be expecting macsafe wireless charging
being added which is gonna be huge
allowing you to reverse wireless charger
airpods or iPhone on the back as well as
the release of a brand new updated magic
keyboard with macsafe support on the
back as well on top of that we're
looking for forward to the biggest
display upgrade of all time with thinner
bezels than we currently have as well as
the release of the best display in the
entire industry a hybrid dual OLED
screen that fixes all of the past
display issues by having no Halo glow
effect in dark scenes but also having
incredibly High brightness due to
stacking two OLED panels together for a
perfect contrast ratios and HDR
basically the best display ever made
adding on to that we can also expect the
Swiss to a horizontally placed camera
which the budget iPad already has and
will be getting an update to the M3 chip
and we could even get a new Apple pencil
3. and now moving on to reason number
three we have the iPad Air 6 which I
believe will 100 percent be getting
updated either next month or in October
and here's why Apple's iPad Air has been
on a one point a five-year cycle for the
last couple of models always getting
released in either the spring or the
fall and guess what it's been just about
one and a half years since the current
iPad Air 5 was released so everything is
lining up for a new iPad air update now
some might say that it's not getting
upgraded until the spring of next year
but I say no because Apple never updates
the air and the pro at the same time
they always specifically separate the
releases for those two products because
they're right next to each other in the
iPad lineup and since we know the iPad
Pros are getting updated in the spring
apple either has to upgrade the air this
fall or wait until next fall and I fully
believe that that would be too late
since they would have to give the air
the same M3 chip as the iPad Pro but if
they update the iPad Air next month they
can easily give it the M2 Chip and get a
bunch of sales before they reveal the M3
chip in October or November for Apple's
MacBooks so that's why I think it's
coming as soon as next month now this
time around I would say that we
shouldn't expect anything more than a
chip upgrade to the M2 and the switch to
a horizontally placed camera but those
are still a couple of great upgrades to
wait for instead of buying right now and
being stuck with older Tech getting it
to reason number four we also have the
iPad Mini 7 which I believe will be
coming alongside the iPad Air 6 mainly
because next month it's going to be
exactly two years since the release of
the current iPad Mini so it's actually
due for an upgrade and keep in mind that
back in 2019 Apple released both the
iPad Air 3 and iPad Mini 5 at the same
time and not only that but shrimp Alpha
pro has leaked that the 7th gen iPad
mini is currently in the works by Apple
and is coming soon so basically I
believe this iPad Mini will be a simple
chip and wireless spec update with newer
Wi-Fi and Bluetooth tech and as far as
which chip it's going to be getting I
believe it's either going to be the new
a17 chip which hints at a September
event release or apple might actually
just give it the same M2 Chip as the
upcoming ear which would make sense if
Apple wants to reserve all of the new
three nanometer a17 chips just for the
iPhone 15 Pros to help with chip Supply
but I would definitely recommend waiting
because either one of those chips will
still be a huge upgrade and now
finishing off with reason number five
even if you're not interested in any of
these new iPad upgrades you should still
wait on buying because what usually
happens is that the current models start
to go on sale for really great deals as
soon as the new ones come out so you can
save even more money if you wait so with
all that said hopefully this video is
going to help you get a a better iPad by
waiting to buy so if this helped you out
you can subscribe right there and check
out one of those two videos right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
foreign